So Carl, you've been at Google for
awhile now.
>> Six years.
>> And it sounds like.
Wow six years.
And it sounds like prototyping
has changed over that time.
Can you just sort of talk a little
bit about how that's happened?
>> Yeah, prototyping has evolved
quite a bit in my tenure at Google.
When I first came to search, for
instance, almost three years ago,
we were focused heavily on creating
web products specifically for
their desktop users.
Google's shift has grown significantly
over the last few years.
And we've gone mobile first.
And so as a result, I've had to evolve
with the times and have also shifted
my development practices towards
doing full time Android development.
>> Mm-hm.
So you now sort of lead
a team of Android developers.
>> That's right.
So I lead a team of four people,
specifically looking at search, map and
identity products across Google.
>> Awesome.
And I know you've worked on some
things in their earlier stages,
that's one of the joys of prototyping,
you get to see these things before they
happen and some of them never do happen.
But can you tell me a little
about working on material design?
>> Sure, material design was a fantastic
project to work on, we spent about
a year ramping up on that before we
ever released anything to the public.
I think in its infancy we were thinking
about it, we called it quantum paper,
and we were really thinking about this
idea that it was digital paper, and so
we were thinking about how does digital
paper do things like respond to touch.
How do we show layers for instance,
inside of that digital paper landscape.
We made a number of prototypes across
the early stages of that project.
We even did some really ugly ones
with some really bad electronic
mesh-like touch responsiveness stuff.
>> Mm-hm.
>> That ultimately,
we did away with a lot of that stuff
in favor of a really simple UI and so
that's where we ended going with the
touch ripples, for instance, in Android.
I think a much better experience for
our users.
It's a little simpler, a little bit
cleaner and I think as a result a bit
more delightful than some of the early
mesh-tron like stuff we were doing.
>> Right, that makes sense.
And so some of these decisions you
made to sort of scrap this version
of a product and
come out with this simpler one.
Was that made based on user feedback?
Was that made based on some
other kind of feedback?
Was that made out of the blue?
>> Not really out of the blue.
We got tons and tons of feedback.
We as a group of designers and
developers were sequestered for
a couple of months
working on the project.
We got lots and lots of feedback from
not only the executive sponsors of
the project but then a number of design
stakeholders as well as a lot
of users that we did tests with.
We did some guerilla cafe-style
testing across the Google campus.
We even brought in
outside trusted testers
to give us their feedback
on the experience.
>> So you mentioned that
native prototyping has
sort of come to the forefront at Google.
>> That's right.
>> Can you talk a little bit about
why that is and sort of what you get out
of that that you wouldn't be able to get
out of just a web prototype
that you've put on on a phone.
>> Sure, one of the areas
that I think we have focused
a great deal of energy is actually
in prototyping voice experiences.
This is an area that we can't do a whole
lot as far as the web side of things.
For instance, we're limited by some
platform vendors in the access that we
have to their API's.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So
going with a fully native experience
means that we get a much wider set of
tools that we can work with.
So for instance,
in the we get much tighter
integration with voice components.
>> Right.
>> We can do a really beautiful voice
experience, lot's of delightful
animation around that experience as
we bring that prototype or
that application to life.
>> Perfect, thank you.